the jurogan experience
when did san francisco shift because
i've i've been going to san francisco
to do stand-ups since the 1990s and i
don't know when i noticed there was
always homeless people but they
they were not camping like it wasn't as
chaotic as like you're never gonna get
away from a certain amount of mental
illness correct right you're never gonna
get away with certain amount of drug
addicts and there's you know it's a
thing with cities
when did it get where it is and how what
were the steps right
so it you really have to go back so
culturally san francisco has been very
tolerant of drug use since the 19th
century it had opium dems dens that it
was the last to shut down of anybody in
the 19th century but then you really go
then the of the 60s and a celebration of
drug culture in the 60s people think of
it being psychedelics and marijuana but
it also included amphetamines and heroin
i mean you go back to janice joplin in
the 60s she was doing heroin do you know
that that's also where the cia did
operation midnight climax i'm not
surprised yeah that's where they did
there where they would have brothels and
they would dose the johns up with lsd
and observe them through two-way mirrors
i'm not surprised yeah it's it's so it's
a cult a very libertarian culture right
so it makes sense that it's it's that
way
but then i think you have to go to the
1990s uh with the heart which the
movement that i was involved in harm
reduction also had at the same time it
wasn't exactly the same movement but it
was also
expanded treatment of pain
through opioids and that's the beginning
of the opioid epidemic really begins
with the liberalization of opioids so
that we just over prescribed opioids
right it's now a famous story in the
united states we we just gave them away
to too many people a lot of um
people that probably should have
received an antidepressant or maybe some
medicine for adhd
or were just depressed were getting
opioids and their doctors were
encouraged to do it obviously the
pharmaceutical industry encouraged it
obama then we we started restricting
that around 2010
and then a lot of those people then
switched to heroin
and then and then meanwhile in the
background really growing from the 60s
but just getting more and more
intensified and concentrated is meth so
you have two separate epidemics meth and
opioids and they both kill
now we're into we're into next
generation opioids from heroin which is
fentanyl which is something that you've
covered here a lot um and so that's how
you get these just rising so you
basically on the one hand you get
gradually increasing death toll from
that 17 000 in the year 2000 to 93 000
last year but fentanyl also is
game-changing and so it's much easier
usually heroin it's harder to overdose
usually it's because of mixing with
alcohol or benzodiazepines
but you get to fentanyl and it's much
easier to just overdose directly on
fentanyl and now the narcans not working
as well against the fentanyl
so that's basically it now the tents i
tried to answer this question and
there's disagreement about it but
definitely occupy brought a lot of tense
into the homeless community interested
in 2011 i mean i remember around in
oakland where i was working at the time
there were all these occupy tents at the
down in front of the city center and the
same thing in san francisco and then
after occupy ended the activists the
anarchist activists just gave the tents
to the homeless
and you know it's it seems like a nice
thing to do right like here you have a
tent to stay in it seems like the
compassionate thing to do but then it
basically just grew out of control and
so we call you know we euphemize it by
calling it an encampment you know it
makes it sound like it's a happy camp
but we know that you know women are
raped in those camps mentally ill people
are taken advantage of people overdose
and die people are killed when you can't
make payment for your drugs the the drug
dealers stab you with a machete
so these are really violent dangerous
terrible places you get hepatitis
because of all the feces so
it just spiraled out of control so it's
hard to it's hard to pinpoint any single
thing but i think yeah for sure like
occupy 10 years ago
and then just a you know i mean we even
see
basically cities and police becoming
more liberal around public drunkenness
in like the 70s and the 1980s when
homelessness really emerged
you mentioned comic relief i mean
comedians actually did a real disservice
on this issue new billy crystal whoopi
goldberg robin williams
by suggesting that homelessness was a
problem of poverty
it was really a result of the crack
epidemic crack and alcohol certainly
there were economic forces involved but
but progressives have just badly misled
people into thinking that this is a
problem of high rents
is this just because it feels good to
like rally against the rich and to say
that we need to just be compassionate
and then is that what it is
yeah i think that if i had to summarize
it i i quote this amazing addiction
specialist from stanford keith humphries
who calls it left libertarianism
so it's basically this idea and this is
where the book ends up going is that to
victims give everything and demand
nothing you know that's it's a
combination of a radical left
view but also combined with the
libertarianism
so that's what's kind of behind it i
mean you i interview university people
and they just think it's immoral to
demand anything from addicts or from
homeless people how dare you you know
how dare you ask them to change their
behavior they're victims of all these
terrible things in a lot of cases they
are
but the whole thing is that nobody to to
to suggest that somebody's essentially a
victim
actually ends up being
i think racist the idea that all black
people are victims i think is a racist
idea the idea that all white people are
benefiting from privilege also a racist
idea but that kind of racism it's a
different kind of racism than the the
type that we're all used to which was
you know racism type one was how do we
justify enslaving africans basically and
how do we justify prejudicial policies
against you know people of color mostly
type two comes out of
guilt you know and so really it starts
in the 60s um you know at a point where
we passed civil rights legislation 1964
you get to 1970 and this very famous
book gets published called uh blaming
the victim
and the idea is that
basically any policies that demand some
accountability and taking of personal
responsibility is effectively a kind of
victimization watch the entire episode
for free only on spotify